hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff we are back at the 1921 World
Chess Championship match between Emanuel
asker and josé raúl capablanca
we've already covered 11 games of the
championship this is game 12 and so far
kappa blanka is 3 points in the lead and
he also won the previous two games they
played so both wood white and the black
piece in a row now let's see what Laster
can do to get back into the match and
what his strategy will be so game 12
Lasker vs. capablanca on 1921 vulture
championship match
Lasker opens with E for with E 5 by
capablanca Knight to f3 Knight to c6 and
now Bishop to b5 again we entered the
real Lopes with Knight to f6 castles by
Lasker and d6 now with d4 by Lasker
Bishop to d7 by Capablanca in the now
Knight to c3 with Bishop to e7 and now
rook to e1 with more defense than the e4
pawn and now e capture some b4 we have
Knight captures and here kappa blanka
castles now the main move today is just
captures on c6 but Lasker talks the
bishop back for for later use with
Bishop to f1 and now rook to e8 and it's
interesting that the disposition has
never again happened after this game was
played with f3 Lasker strengthens the
center and now push up the f8 opening up
the e-file for the rook with Bishop to
g5 now pinning the knight and h6 kappa
blanka pushes the bishop back with the
shift to h4 and now even g6 and here
with the g6 Capablanca gave Alaska a
very interesting idea Lasker played
Knight to d5 he decided to go after the
pinned piece and prepare nice the b5 to
go after the c 7.0 Blanca doesn't like
this idea there was a very interesting
choice of Knight captures on c6 and
after Bishop captures just he 5 and now
you're unable to recapture
if you recapture then then you lose the
knight on f6 for example pawn captures
now we just eliminate the Queen and the
Queen no longer defends the knight on f6
so just a bunch of characters and f6
wins apiece so after E 5 you would be
forced to play
five just take away this tension here
and then you get each captures G
captures and now you have this position
where a couple one can structure is all
messed up
so this was one way to go about it but
Lasker tries a different line like we
said first night that the five goes
after the night here Bishop to g7
capablanca defense and now again
capablanca says c3 is just the way to go
for last we're here just keeping
everything in the position but Lasker
goes the night to b5 so now the c7 point
is under attack but capablanca says that
the combinations that arise from this
position should favor black so he plays
g5 pushes the bishop back and then now
Knight D captures on c7 so attacking
both of the both of the rooks with G
chapters on h4 Knight captures on a
eight queen cap for something eight and
the now of course winning back the
exchange Knights the c7 by last four
attacking the Queen and the rook Queen
goes back Queen d8 and not Knight
captures on e eight we have Knight
captures any a tendon out rook to be one
you don't want to diss rook on a one as
the bishop controls this very strong
diagonal Bishop to e6 by capablanca
Lasker is up upon but Capablanca has the
bishop pair and it's you know bishop
repair is compensation enough for the
pawn in this position as there is play
on both sides of the board and it is not
all that easy to defend all of those
pawns on the Queen side Alaska has so
here at Alaska played c3 and he asks a
couple Lanka do you want to play a bunch
of character Sunday - then I get rook to
a one I have this semi open file for my
rook I give back the pawn in the game
continues and here couple Blanca did
play Bishop captures on a2 but later
Capablanca said that he he felt that he
had a winning position here but that he
should have played Bishop to e5 and
indeed Bishop to e5 is a very strong
move and it really threatens a lot of a
lot of things for example if you play
something like a three just to show you
the threads behind Bishop to e5 you're
gonna get Queen g5 and now ideas like
Queen f4 to h2 are are on the board and
white will play Queen c1 offer a trade
Queens now you'll push the Queen back
brush up to f4 Queen to c2 enter now for
example Queenie five and there is no
defense against well th pawn is lost you
can't push g3 otherwise the whole
position just explodes and well whatever
you do if you push h3
that's even worse you're just gonna for
example you can get a queen there then
you can start chasing the king you can
get your knight into the game put a
knight on G 3 there are a lot of ways
you can play this but all you know
that's just a terrible position for
whites to be in so this is what
capablanca could have played Bishop to
e5 but he decided for Bishop capture
Sunday to know why it wasn't really a
matter of being low on time he wasn't
long time here but maybe just the the
fact that he was already up three points
in the match that he just doesn't want
to take any chances give ask her any
counter play whatsoever he just grabs
his extra pawn and says okay I'm still
three points in the lead
you're the one who has to get back into
this match so rook to a one attacking
couple Blancas Bishop Ussher back to e6
and now Queen to d2 couple Blanca goes
a6 now the knight can move as the knight
no longer has to keep an eye on the pawn
on a seven and now Queen to f2 putting
pressure on the h4 pawn if you for
example play a knight here then the poem
can be captured so h5 and now it's again
very hard for whites to actually do
something here the pawns are really
annoying here and the capablanca is
about the start and attack on the King
side
so with f4 by Lasker and the now comes
Bishop to h6 now that the h6 Square has
been free for Capablanca special and now
Bishop to e2 going after the h5 point f5
doesn't really do anything it seems nice
but after the bishop retreats you've
just given black the e5 square and from
there the night can be a very annoying
piece so Alaska plays but stuff to e2
who goes after the pawn here and now you
can't really prevent the Bishop captures
on h5 you could play Bishop g4 but it
doesn't really do all that much for
black for example if you just trade ESU
one double black spawns but e five after
E 5 you'll get D cap
F captures and now what do you play here
it will be it will be difficult to keep
an eye on those pawns as for example
after something like 97 Queen e2
attacking the pawn and after black
defends it now you did a route k4 and
you're going to lose those pawns so
you're not going to be able to use them
for attack
so after Bishop d2 Capablanca saw that
yeah bishop the g2 isn't Bishop to g4
isn't all that great now let's go into
some trades he played Knight to f6 now
he offered the h4 pawn for the e4 pawn
and last week captures with Queen
captures on h4 Knight captures on e4
Queen captures and e8 Knight captures
and now both Bishop captures on age five
and a six are nice as it opens up a
discovery towards the night Alaska
chooses bushel captures on age six
so with d5 defending the knight and now
just the bishop back to e2 going after
the h5 pawn Capablanca captures on f4
with Bishop captures and h5 and now
Bishop back to c7 by Capablanca Lasker
played rook a to d1 here and it was in
fact in this position unmoved 31 that
the game was adjourned
and then the players had 24 hours to
think about the position and after they
thought about the position for 24 hours
they agreed to it to a draw Alaska is up
upon here but capablanca has a very
dangerous bishop pair now if anything
can happen from this position I'm sure a
lot of things can happen in this
position and of course alas we're having
two rooks and the bishop whereas
Capablanca has four pieces it's a it's a
it's a bit of a trade-off but all in all
it's a cup of markup with the two
bishops for example Bishop to b6 and if
this bishop somehow assumes this
diagonal it could be very dangerous for
Lasker it's very unlikely that last word
can push for more for more than a half a
point here he can just lose and go down
even further in the match
Agha rez capablanca he's very happy
would roll with the black pieces he
doesn't have to prove anything or push
for anything more than a draw here next
game he gets the white pieces and then
he will try to prove some points there
so this is game 12 of the 1921 World
Championship match between
last brand hostel Capablanca I do hope
you enjoyed it and yeah we're going for
game 13 probably today we'll see how it
goes but yeah I'm planning on finishing
the the match either today or tomorrow
and with this we will finish our entire
Capablanca saga even though there are
more games Capablanca played a lot more
games that he played after the world's
championship match but we'll use those
as standalone tournaments or as part of
some other sagas for example now with
them that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank Pablo
Mohan and Jeff graves for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank all for
watching and I will see soon continuing
the capablanca saga and of course
checking up on your awesome suggestions
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day